[Musik]
[Applaus]
dramatische bilder an der iranisch
afghanischen grenze auf einem video das
auf twitter kursiert ist zu sehen wie
hunderte afghanen über gebirgige gelände
ins nachbarland iran fliehen über
steilhänge teilweise nur mit sandalen
bekleidet
hauptsache erstmal raus aus der taliban
hölle seit der machtübernahme der
taliban und dem abzug der letzten us
truppen in der nacht zu dienstag steht
für viele afghanen kaum noch hoffnung in
ihrem heimatland zu überleben
diese flüchtlinge werden natürlich und
wollen natürlich nicht im iran bleiben
vom iran geht die route weiter in die
türkei von der türkei weiter nach
griechenland und wir kennen diese route
aus dem jahr 2015 nur zu gut sie endet
so ist es zumindest der wunsch vieler
menschen die jetzt fliehen bei uns in
deutschland und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass deutschland sich jetzt auf
das vorbereitet was dort gerade passiert
wie iran ist seit jahrzehnten neben
pakistan das haupt aufnahmeland für
flüchtlinge aus afghanistan
es sollen sich dort laut schätzungen bis
zu drei millionen afghanen aufhalten
[Musik]